hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast latest developments in
high titer transient protein expression
using the XP Cho transient expression
system presented by dr. John zmuda
director of cell biology a life sciences
solutions group Thermo Fisher Scientific
I'm julissa Maura and I will be your
moderator for this educational webcast
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
get Co part of thermo Fisher Scientific
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question in the box that appears on the
screen will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem please join me in
welcoming dr. John zmuda I will now turn
the presentation over to him thank you
for the introduction and good morning
good afternoon and good to everybody on
the line today
this is Jonathan zmuda director of cell
biology at our Frederick Maryland site
for Thermo Fisher about 30 minutes due
north of Washington DC on the east coast
of the United States unfortunately I
will have to apologize that my webcam we
had technical difficulties this morning
so unfortunately this will be a slides
only telephone conversation what I would
like to do is take you through some of
the latest developments in our high
titer transient show XP Cho system and
for those of you who have never worked
with the system before I'd like to go
through
of the system's components and how they
were developed and how they work in
conjunction with one another to maximize
the protein titers that you can obtain
from each expression run and then later
in the presentation we'll go through
some applications notes around scale up
and scale down with the system as well
as purification and other tips and
tricks for optimizing the system and
also ensuring that the system is running
at peak performance for each one of your
expression runs so I'll start by going
through the XP Cho system components
first and as with any protein expression
system the foundation of the system lies
upon the cells themselves and with XP
Cho we went back into our cell banks
that are that we utilize for our GMP Cho
s cell line and we went further back
into the lineage to generate some
diversity in those cells and then we
tested through clone picks this settled
and picked high expressing clones from
those early chill s cell banks so the XP
Cho s cell line is a completely natural
sub clone of the Cho s cell line so
there's been no engineering to the cells
in in any manner and these settles were
picked based on a number of critical
attributes that are necessary to have a
good cell line for transient protein
expression so firstly for protein for
transient protein expression of course
the cells have to be able to generate
high titers of protein and as we look at
the specific productivity estimated for
the XP cho cells during what you would
call log phase protein expression we see
that we have a picogram per cell per day
productivity of about 30 PCD which is
quite good and rivals many stabili
expressing cho cell lines the second
attribute that's critical for these
cells is that they have a short doubling
time so that the cells grow rapidly
they're available for use when you're
ready to perform your expression runs
and you're able to obtain a high density
cell growth which allows for very high
density transection in the
p-chaw system so the XP geocells have a
very rapid doubling time of about 17
hours so these cells will roughly triple
each day when they're at log phase
growth and we'll show some more data
along those lines cell performance in
the next slide and then thirdly one of
the other very key attributes to a good
transient expression cell line is that
these cells have a very non clumping
morphology so if you were to compare for
example the xB cello s cells versus
typical cello cells in in Culture Media
in a growth curve type scenario you
would see that the choez cells will get
clumpy about a third to a halfway
through their maximum density cell
growth whereas the xB Cho cells and
shown again in the in the bottom-right
on the screen will continue to maintain
a very nice single cell morphology even
to quite high densities so that is
important because this allows for us to
culture this particular clone up to high
densities without the use of any anti
clumping reagents that would also be
highly detrimental to transfection of
the cells themselves so these three key
attributes really make the xbg OS cell
line very useful for high density high
titer transient protein expression so as
I go through the next slides also talk a
little bit about how to troubleshoot
these cells and the cell growth what
they should look like out of thaw and
again these cells are adapted for high
density culture so in standard shape
flasks they will obtain approximately or
greater than 20 million cells per mil
during normal growth these cells also
have the ability in conjunction with the
expecto mean cho transfection reagent
and other system components to have a
very high transfection efficiency
something that was previously attainable
only in 293 cells that were expected to
be easily transected so line
additionally another key attribute for
any cell line in transient expression
system is stable growth in expression
profiles and what we'll show later in
the presentation also is that the
expression profiles for the XP choke
cells tend to be stable through about 15
to 2
five passages and that is also dependent
upon of course how the cells are handled
during that time how they are maintained
in a culture so that the cells are not
stressed from passage to passage and
then lastly and we'll touch on this
toward the end of the presentation we
wanted to ensure that the cells had for
example show like like oscillation
profiles so that the glycan is coming
out of the transient system match those
very closely that were generated and
show us in a stable setting so upon
receipt of the cells the XP cho cells
should recover very quickly post fall
and so in the upper right hand figure
you'll see the following of four cell
vials of XP gos cells and in blue is the
viable cell density where you'll note
that from day 0 to day 1 in the first 24
hours the cells will roughly double in
density and again double between day 1 &
2 and then by the time you're at day 2
to 3 these cells are already starting to
take off into their normal log phase
growth and you can see between days
three and day 4 the cells have really
taken off and are growing very rapidly
in the red line above you see the
corresponding viability profiles so you
may see a very small dip in viability
immediately post fall but by day two the
cells have already recovered to very
high viability 98 + % routinely in
subculture and if for any reason the
cells upon fall do not appear to have
these growth characteristics that's
something that it would be good then to
bring up with our technical team or also
just to ensure that the cells had been
the Chain of Custody had been maintained
in the cells have not followed and
refrozen for example at any stage upon
receipt so these cells should take off
very quickly and be in a rapidly growing
single cell morphology immediately post
fall what we show on the right hand side
is X peach OS cells and we're again
looking at viable cell density on the
left hand y axis as well as viability on
the right hand axis and
cells were seated at three different
densities ranging from 0.125 to 0.5
times 10 to the 6 million cells per mil
and what you see is that in each one of
these instances you will you able we
were able to obtain over 20 million
cells per mil and shake flask cultures
so of course there are some differences
in all counting measurements between
instruments hemocytometer zet cetera so
we we say typically this is a good way
that you can test for the ability of
your cell growth conditions to be
optimized by simply seeding the cells at
one of these densities you know
typically 0.25 times 10 to the 6 and
allowing them to go out for five to
seven days and ensuring that you're
getting somewhere in the ballpark of 20
million cells per mil again give or take
assuming variances of 10 to 15% or
perhaps even more between counting
methodologies so this is an excellent
way to make sure that the cells are
growing under the the correct conditions
in your laboratory so the second part of
the xbo system that is critical to allow
us for these very high density and long
expression runs to take advantage of the
characteristics the inherent
characteristics of the cho cells that
make them very good a very good cell
line for bio production is the x bt o
feed that was formulated specifically to
be matched with the x bicho expression
media both of which are protein free
animal arjun free chemically defined
formulations and what we show on the
bottom left-hand side is for example the
xB Cho system has three different
protocols that gives the user an option
in terms of both the duration and the
temperature of the protocol used so xB
Cho has three protocols one the first
being the standard protocol in which you
have a single feed Edition and the
entire protocol runs at 37 C and then we
also have high titer and Max titer
protocols in which you have a first feed
Edition 18 to 22 hours post transection
followed by a temperature shift to 32 C
and then in the case of the max titer
protocol shown on the left
we have a second edition of feed on or
about day five and what we show here on
the bottom left is the robustness in
terms of the ability of the system to
handle addition of the feed at different
days so if the feed were required to be
added on day four that has no impact on
the titer day five in the second bar
from the the left is where we normally
recommend to add the second feet and
then day six you may see a very slight
impact on tighter but even out to day
seven the cells will not crash but it is
that extra boost of nutrients that can
really help those cells to push out to
12 to 14 days expression runs where for
very stable proteins you can obtain
significant significantly higher titers
so the one other caveat just for
simplicity is that the xpo feed does not
need to be warmed prior to addition to
the culture flasks and in fact in the
next slide I'll further give advice on
simplification of the addition of the
feed and enhancer simultaneously on the
bottom right what we show is just one of
the small changes that we implemented to
the revised XP choke protocol that was
available online in December of 2016 so
for those of you that have been using XP
chow for over over a year coming up on
two years now please do take a moment to
download the new version of the protocol
it has a lot of additional information
and tips for optimizing expression and
and generating the highest
reproducibility possible one small
change that we made for the sake of
simplicity was that for the standard and
high titer protocols each which have a
single feed we made them correspondingly
both at a single feed of 24 percent so
now those two protocols are exactly the
same as one another with the exception
of the temperature shift so to alleviate
any confusion there and what you can see
in the bottom right again is that even
at lower percentages of feed at 20
percent feed or 24 percent in the top
two lines we can maintain identical
titers no loss in titer all the way out
in this case two to twelve days whereas
at lower percentages of feed shown in
green you will start to see the
rushon levels drop off a bit sooner
without those added nutrients and
finally in the red curve at the 30
percent feed we do see some impact of
osmotic stress at 30 percent which has
slightly slower kinetics of antibody
production and so for all of these
reasons we have simplified the protocol
so that both standard and high titer
protocols now run with a single 24
percent feed very importantly to the xB
Cho system is the X vector means show
enhancer cocktail and this cocktail
effectively greater than doubles the
protein titers that we were able to
obtain from the exp Cho cells and once
again the enhancer does not need to be
warmed before adding it to the the cells
and importantly in bullet three you see
that the X BTO feed enhancer may be
mixed together ahead of time so that
you're doing only a single addition to
your flasks or multi-well plates and in
fact in this this strategy was looked
into for the multi-well plates in
particular so that you're not having to
do multiple very small additions of
enhancer and feed and so on the bottom
left really a quite telling graph of why
the utilization of all the system
components together for xB Cho is
critical to maximize the value in the
performance of the system if you look on
the far left bar if we simply transect
the xB Cho cells in there in their
growth media and we do not add enhancer
and feed the titers will be very low so
on the order of perhaps one to two
hundred mix per liter which of course
for cho cell expression is still
actually quite good but in the middle
you see so stepping back to that what
will happen to those cells is that in
essence they will be transfected they're
very healthy after transfection these
cells like to grow and they'll grow
within the next day or so to their 20
million peak density and crash and they
will actually use most of their energy
to grow instead of produce protein so in
the in the middle you see when we simply
add the feed to the system so without
the enhancer in this case we can obtain
much higher about 5 times or 6 times
higher titers
in the absence of the fee and the fee
has two different impacts on the cells
one is that it does have componentry
that helps to slow the cell growth down
so that again the cells use their energy
for making protein as opposed to growing
and secondly it provides of course the
nutrients for the cells to grow and the
feed has been developed with a numerous
proprietary components that allow for
those components to remain stable at
very high concentrations that are
required for the cho cells but on the
far right is where you see the true
value of the entire system and the
synergistic impacts of having a cell
line adapted and matched to a media with
a high efficiency transfection reagent a
custom tailored feed and then an
enhancer cocktail that allows these
cells again to be very controlled in
terms of their cell growth but produce
protein for many days and you can see
here that from using the feed alone to
using the full system with the enhancer
in the feed you've more than double
almost triple the titers that are
obtainable from these cells so critical
all critical components of the system
and all in the manner in which the
system has been developed as the system
to provide the highest titers when all
components are used in concert on the
bottom right you see data from when we
mixed the enhancer and the feed either
and held it for either one day or two
weeks at Ford at two to eight C or added
it fresh in a in a sequential addition
of enhancer and feed to the flasks and
so what you can see is that and our
recommendation typically is that on the
day that you're adding your feed and
enhancer they can be prepared ahead of
time and held at two to eight C and then
again add it as a single addition to
your flasks or plates and in fact this
formulation is even stable out too we
show here two weeks at two to eight C no
degradation in performance or titer
from the system so again just a nice tip
to save you from multiple PI pettings go
ahead and
ahead of time and add them singly to the
flasks another very key component to the
system is the XP Chow transfection
reagent and so what we show on the left
and the bar graph is GFP percent
transfection efficiency in XP to 93
cells where we can reach approximately
90% transfection efficiency again a very
easy note known easy to transect cell
line freestyle max shows so the older
shows system where we can get you know
forty to fifty percent transfection
efficiency on the best day and then XP
show in each of the three protocols
where we're obtaining on or about 80
percent transfection efficiency of cho
cells at very high density so for xB to
93 the cells are transfected at 3
million freestyle max chose at 1 million
and XP Cho is actually transected at 6
million cells per mil so this
transfection region has very special
characteristics that allow for high
density high efficiency transfection of
cho cells that has never really been
possible previously for cho cells and
there are a number of very key tips for
using the x perfect Ameen show
transfection reagent that I'll go
through the next couple slides to
maximize both titers and reproducibility
and this is in part due to the special
characteristics of this transfection
reagent that allow for it to be a more
powerful transfection reagent to
transect these high density Cho cultures
so as the best practice we recommend
that prior to your complex ation that
you dilute your plasmid DNA in cold opti
Pro first and that is very stable for
long periods of time and then when
you're ready to make your complexes you
dilute your x perfecta mean show into
hot d pro cold oxy pro right at the time
that you're ready to make your complex
ations immediately complex the plasmid
DNA and the X vector mean show and I'll
show in the next slide but mix once or
twice by pipetting or gentle inversion
and then those complexes are immediately
ready to be added to your flasks so xB
Cho requires essentially no whole time
or complex
and time that I'll show in the next
slide but what I do show here is that
allowing X perspective each o2 to sit
diluted in opti Pro for long periods of
time can actually compromise the
performance of the transfection reagent
the thought behind that being that
because it is a stronger transfection
reagent that it may partly start to self
complex on its own with components of
the of the expression media so one of
two ways that the second alternative
path that works very well next effect
Amin show is that as an alternative to
this and what we suggest in the
scaled-down protocols for simplicity as
well in the automation protocol is that
you simply doubly dilute your plasmid
DNA with the entire volume of opti Pro
that you would normally use to dilute
the transection region and the DNA and
then whatever you're ready to complex
your DNA you can simply add the expecto
mean show transfection reagent neat to
your doubly diluted plasmid DNA so in
essence a 1/2 complex ation reaction and
that has titers that are identical to
the two tube complex ation reaction so
again here these are just some you know
important tips for maximizing both
performance and reproducibility of the
system and then what I show on this
slide again is the best practices for
the actual complex ation reaction so in
the last slide we talked about diluting
the expo specta mean show with cold
octave Pro when you're ready to make
your complexes and then here we're
showing data that once you add your
diluted transfection reagent and diluted
plasmid DNA in essence again you can mix
a couple times by gentle pipetting up
and down or inversion and then
immediately add them to your to your
flash deterrent effect so what we show
here is less than one minute of complex
ation time and up to five minutes of
complex ation times you see no decrease
in titers and once you hold the
complexes for more than ten or twenty
minutes you will see some decreases in
titer
likely again due to the complexes
continuing to form and becoming slightly
less able to transect the cells so while
this is a bit of a paradigm shift in
terms of transfection reagents once
you're used to doing so we hear very
positive feed
because in essence on the morning of
your transection you can grab all of
your reagents out of the refrigerator
use them all cold perform your complex
Asian reaction and literally within five
to ten minutes from the time you go to
your refrigerator to transect your cells
your cells are transfected so it's a
significant time savings in terms of
transecting the cells and then when I
get to the automation slides later we'll
will discuss the ways in which we change
the per or change the protocol a bit
just to allow for the smoothest running
on the automated systems again here just
bring you home the point that gentle
mixing of the complexation reaction is
the is the best way to form the
complexes so vortexing or rough very
rough mixing by pipetting up and down
ten times very vigorously actually over
forms the complexes and while these are
not toxic to the cells you will not see
a reducing reduction in viability you
will see a reduction in tighter so again
upon complex ation one or two Pi
pettings to mix or gentle inversion and
you're ready to transect your cells
another very interesting aspect of the X
vector mutual reagent is how little DNA
we can use even in light of the fact
that we're transfecting six million
cells per mil so twice as high as X b-29
3 and six times as high as as most
typical transmission protocols so XP Cho
typically is optimal in about a point
six to 0.8 microgram per mil range of
plasma DNA versus a microgram per mil
which is the industry standard for most
systems and in fact even utilizing less
DNA you can still get very good titers
so the transfection reagent is very
efficiently transfecting and delivering
the DNA to the cells for the proteins to
be made what we show in this figure is
actually the a single concentration at a
single volume of XP tectum eto
transfection reagent as noted in the
protocol complexed with different levels
of plasma DNA from point two up to one
point two and again typically in our
experiences levels higher than point
eight are not beneficial and in fact you
you can start to see slight viability
dips at those higher DNA concentrations
when moving to the lower concentrations
of DNA point two point four or even
lower which we have evidence that
suggests that for some hard to express
proteins significant significantly
lowering the concentration of plasmid
DNA can be beneficial or in instances
where you're limited in terms of your
plasmid DNA or in large-scale
preparations and what we don't show in
this slide but what you do reduce your
plasmid DNA to point four point two it
is beneficial at this point actually if
you're looking to go in that direction
to utilize a bit less of the
transfection reagent so reducing it
proportionally to the point four or
point two while keeping the entire
complex ation volume the same and in
doing so those titers with the very low
amounts of plasmid DNA will actually
come closer to approaching the control
titers that you see here for the point 6
micrograms plasmid DNA and beyond lastly
with regards to the plasmid DNA we and
many others have found that the optimal
heavy change a light chain ratio for x
bicho is a one-to-one ratio in contrast
to the 293 cell that typically run at a
1/2 to heavy to light chain ratios the
cho cells do a very good job expressing
the light chain and thus one-to-one
ratio is consistently seen to be an
optimal starting point for the XP Cho
system one of the new things that we're
looking at that we'll just share today
that's in the works is actually
modulation of glycan patterns in XP cho
and so we have developed some prototype
reagents that allow for the modulation
of these glyco forms in the XP Cho
system and why is this important this is
important because different cho cells
and and different clones of the cho
cells maintained in different
laboratories for many years and
different media conditions and different
feed conditions and expression
conditions have differences in glycan
profiles and certainly for biosimilars
it is optimal to have your material of
course your transient
we'll be as similar as possible to your
stable cell line produced material and
of course the first step there is using
cho cells for transient and cho cells
for stable but some cho cells and in
different systems will have different
like elastic like oscillation profiles
and what we show here is some prototype
reagents that we've been working on that
allows for us to modulate the glycan
patterns of XP Cho so in red we show the
typical XP choke like hand patterns
where we're significantly g0f which is
very characteristic of Cho s cells and
then through the modulation of different
components of the Culture Media we can
we can reduce that level of g0f while
bringing up the the g1f glyco forms and
in fact if you look at in terms of blue
x be 293 that has very complex
carbohydrates comparatively we're
actually able to change the xB Cho like
oscillation profiles almost look like a
very divergent xB to 93 derived material
so while we would not necessarily be
looking to make Cho like oscillation
look like 293 it's very interesting that
we do know that many users show like
oscillation patterns look more similar
to what we show here in in blue and so
the ability in the future to modulate
these glycans should be a significant
benefit for for certain certainly for
biosimilar manufacturers so I'd now like
to go in and the second half of the
presentation and talk about key tips for
optimal performance with the system
having been out for coming up on two
years and many great collaborations and
discussions with the xB Cho users we
have identified those key items that
will ensure that the system is running
at peak performance in your lab and have
no questions in terms of whether or not
you're getting all the protein possible
out of the system so as I mentioned
previously the xB Cho system has three
different protocols differing only in
their feed amounts and
number of feeds and temperatures so if
we look in green here what we call the
xB geo standard protocol in this case
the cells are transfected 18 to 22 hours
later the feed and enhancer is added and
the cells are maintained at 37 c
throughout the duration of the
expression run for this particular human
IgG one antibody on about eight to nine
days in culture we can obtain a gram per
liter which is comparable to what we can
see in Ex b-29 three cells at about six
days post transfection the high titer
protocol everything is the same as I
mentioned is a standard protocol with
the exception that we shift the
temperatures and this hypothermic shift
pays big dividends in the Cho system and
that on day ten to twelve we can nearly
double the titer
up to about two grams per liter and
finally in the max titer protocol where
we break up the feed so that we have two
feeds as well as 32 C protein expression
we can then further bump up by about
another third so in the case of this
antibody very high titers to two plus
almost three grams per liter at in the
case of the max titer protocol we can
achieve that same gram per liter that we
see in X B to 93 on day six using the
the Cho system but obviously the big
difference in the Cho system is that the
Cho system allows us to go out and
obtain two-thirds more protein over the
next seven days compared to the xB to 93
system so X B to 93 is an excellent
system the 293 cells do a great job at
making a lot of protein very quickly but
then they fizzle out and they cannot
maintain the productivity at the same
productivity as the Cho cells can
whereas the Cho cells start off a bit
slower and then ramp up and are able to
make protein for very long periods of
time in this case all the way out to 14
days so we do have recommended harvest
times if we're talking about very stable
proteins like antibodies typically in
the standard protocol we are harvest
around a seven to nine probably day ten
to twelve for the high titer and really
twelve days is about as far as you need
to go for the max titer protocol
the productivity drops off and then of
course as with any protein in any system
considerations have to be given to you
know protein quality post translational
modifications and ease of purification
during the longer expression runs so for
example in a very high titer max titer
expression run of an antibody the there
will be more metabolic waste and build
up and cell debris in the cultures even
with very high viability toward the end
of the cultures which will make the
processing of the supernatant a bit more
challenging and then of course looking
at post translational modifications for
antibodies it's always important to
picked most correctly the the protocol
in the timing of harvest now for non
antibody proteins or less stable
proteins the harvest days may look very
different than this so for membrane
proteins we may be looking at 48 to 72
maybe 96 hours for other non antibody
secreted proteins again depending on
their stability it's really critical to
do a time course of harvest and to
understand where you're getting your
best combination of titer and quality so
in this slide this really summarizes in
a nutshell what's going on in the ex
bicho expression runs and how to
troubleshoot the system so in the top
right you'll see that the viable cell
density if we look at this you can see
at day zero
we've transected the cells at 6 million
cells per mil a day later we've added
the enhancer and the feed and these
cells will typically before we are you
know able to control fully their their
growth they will roughly double maybe a
little bit more in the first in the
first two days but then you see by day
to where these cell cell density is
largely peaked and then in the Green
Line is the 37c standard protocol so
these cells will then maintain a density
of somewhere between about 10 to 12
million cells per mil throughout the
duration of the expression run and in
red you see that this is added with the
max titer protocol and the temperature
shift and so this really is a key
attribute of how the xbo system works
together and I will say that
to control the cells from over growing
it is a absolutely a combination of the
transfection reagent the feed as I
mentioned previously and the enhancer
and again this allows the cells to
utilize their energy for making protein
as opposed to growing in the top right
you see a representative cell size graph
for the xbo cells as they're expressing
protein the cells will go from the 14 to
15 microns to as high as 20 microns
during their peak expression levels as
you see in red here in the max titer
protocol when the cells are really
pumping out a lot of protein and then
they'll say you're relatively stable in
that area and then as the cultures wind
down you'll start to see the the first
notion of the cultures coming to a an
end is that the cell size will drop a
little bit the next day you'll you'll
see a drop in viability so being able to
monitor cell size is one of the first
key indicators for ensuring performance
of the system in the bottom left is
really the key attribute that tells you
whether or not the system is running
correctly in your lab and set up and
optimize correctly the X BTO for a
non-toxic protein like an IgG that we
have here and a very good control to use
in the system is our rabbit IgG control
plasmid that we offer and it comes with
the starter kits that we know has very
good similar viability profiles to what
is shown here so post transfection you
may see a slight dip in the viability of
the cells a percentage or two the cells
recover them very quickly and a
viability curve that looks like this or
similar indicate that the system is
running very well and I'll talk about
troubleshooting in the next slide but we
you know typically would like to see
viability 75% or greater at the time of
harvest and of course depending on your
harvest time if it's earlier in the run
they may even be higher than that that
of course allows easier purification as
well as less potential degradation of
the product and then on the right is
just another example of the differences
that you see in the titers between
between the two protocols so in this
slide again
blowing up the viability figure this is
where we we want to be at the end of the
expression run and I'll go in how to get
there in the next couple slides but in
instances where the system is not set up
correctly and that may be you know of
course everything comes down to your
your flask the flask volume the amount
of volume that your transfecting in that
flask
you're shaking diameter and your shake
speed and of course all of those things
you know need to be optimized and in
cases where one or multiple is
significantly out of range what we've
seen is that on about day four or five
you can see a reduction in the viability
of the cells indicating that you know
the cells are not happy and some
additional optimization should take
place so this is a pretty telltale sign
this is of course these cells are at
very high density at that point they're
just coming off the stress of the
transfection the addition of the feed
and enhancer and when conditions are not
correct usually around day four or five
is a telltale sign that the cultures are
not going well and when the cell starts
to die off like this they'll make very
little protein after that point so it is
critical to you know follow the the
recommendations in the protocol and to
obtain this high viability during the
expression run so again it may not
always be this high this is a non toxic
you know antibody certainly for non
antibody recombinant proteins can be
different but again that's where you
would tailor your harvest to to your
your desired titer and protein quality
and again using our rapid positive
control antibody you should be able to
obtain viability plots similar to this
which indicates that the system overall
is running at optimal levels in your lab
in terms of scalability we are the next
Vito system is scalable from 125 to two
liter using the same conditions and I'll
break these down a little bit further in
the next slide and then once moving to
the three liter shake class that has a
very different shape to it
typically we're operating closer to the
the 75 to 80 RP
range for the 3-liter shake flask and I
will in this slide the these are
indicative of some of the data
empirically derived that has been added
to the ex PTO protocol and updated so
this really is the key to the entire
system and matching the flask size on
the top with the volume to transect in
the first row and this gives you these
media to flask volume ratios that you
see running across so very scalable from
125 to 2 liters and depending on the
volume in the 3 liter flask they will go
range from 1 2 3 to 1 to 3 point 5 so
above 750 ml starting volume in the 3
liter flasks is is not recommended
without optimization so you can go 5 6 7
750 no problem and then of course
matching this to the shape speed so this
is critical the most common shaking
diameters are year nineteen twenty five
and fifty millimeter shaking diameters
and for the 125 to two leader shake
flats we're recommending 125 for the 19
millimeter shakers 120 for the 25
millimeters and 95 for the 50 millimeter
Corbett and on the right hand column for
the 3 liter flats again these change
quite dramatically 75 RPM for the 19
millimeter and actually 80 RPM both for
the 25 and the 50 millimeter shaking
diameter so again those were empirically
determined as those numbers the
theoretical calculations would not have
would not have led to these results so
these have all been tested empirically
and then you see in the case of the flat
type we're recommending vented non
baffled across-the-board I will I will
mention a couple instances where the
baffle class are superior in the next
slide and then what you see here the
final culture volume once the addition
of all feeds and enhancers ranging for
about 35 ml up to one liter in the 3
liter philosophize so in one instance or
actually two instances the baffle class
we found that worked very well for the
xB Cho system at the 125 ml scale and
the 250 ml scale the baffle class
actually worked quite well and will
further enhance protein titers but there
are a few changes that you need to put
into place very minor if using the small
scale baffle flasks above the 250 ml
scale we do not recommend the baffled
flask there is no benefit in using them
but what we do show here is that in the
instance of 125 ml flask size where in
this experiment there was a bit of
variability using a 19 millimeter orbit
and the 125 ml flask size so in black
you see the non baffled flask and red
you see the baffle flies and even by day
5 you can start to see the baffle flash
showing higher titer by day 8 so in this
case the cells had some stress to them
as I showed in the viability plot and
three of these vessels actually have
largely stopped making protein whereas
two still looked quite good and in red
for the baffle Flass all of them are
performing very consistently and again
even higher than the best non baffle
flask we see the same thing all the way
up to day 12 where the non baffle flask
again these three 5s have not made much
more protein and very tight in the upper
right hand corner is the baffle flasks
for the 125 ml condition in general
we've only recommended this for the 19
millimeter shakers that have seen some
variability the baffle flask so there's
two ways to handle that one is to speed
up the shakers to 140 rpm and this again
is captured in the troubleshooting notes
of the protocol or to move to the
baffled flasks
the second potential benefit of the
baffled flash at the 125 ml size is that
is that it does allow you to increase
your transfection volume in fact all the
way up to 50 MLS and on the right you
see that in doing so you simply have to
match the speed for expression to the
volumes in the baffled flasks has shown
on the right here and as you have more
volume the speed has to go higher but in
some instances that can be very
beneficial the ex vitro system always
work also works very well in the mini
bioreactor or spin tubes and what we
show here is just compared to the
control flask a starting volume of 5
- 20 MLS standard protocol and these are
the final volumes once the addition of
the feed and enhancer so very comparable
to what you see in the shake flask and
then the high titer protocol out to day
10 again very comparable to what you see
in the shake flask I'm shown above and
these are captured also in an
application note in this instance we
were using 240 rpms on a 19 millimeter
shaker with about a 30 degree angle once
you get to 10 MLS or greater so at 5 ml
these tubes can still be vertical once
you get to 10 ml ZAR greater in order to
keep the cells in suspension you need to
angle them as shown in the in the tube
rack here at about 30 degrees similarly
the system works very well in the 24
deep well plates so we recommend the
rectangular bottom or the pyramid bottom
plates the round bottom plates also work
comparably we've just seen some better
robustness in terms of broader ranges of
shake speeds that the rectangular bottom
plates are able to provide consistent
results so when the 24 default plates
these are very popular about a three and
a half ml final volume again these are
captured in an application note this
final volume can be changed a little bit
up or down again based on Shakespeare's
and we recommend in general if you're
not working with one of the good high
ends for example the kun or duet system
the plastic plate lids seem to be
superior in terms of evaporation
compared to the gas permeable plate
sealer tapes so we're simply using the
blocks with the plate lids and putting
them into humidified incubators and
leaving them undisturbed during the
duration of the expression run again
shown in red is the control flask versus
the deep wall plates for the standard
and high titer protocol on the left
figure and again on the right this is
the protocol for the 96 deep wall plates
so here again using the plastic plate
libs it's 852 950 rpm on a three
millimeter orbital shaker and the
orbital part of this is very important
so some of the 3 millimeter shakers will
be linear for example for our lives of
plates are similar it is important that
it is a three millimeter orbital shaker
and here we can obtain about a mil of
final value
in the 96 deep wall plates and then
lastly one of the things that we've been
working on and have shared in certain
instances the in comparison to the 293
cells 2 9 3 cells are very inflexible in
terms of what they will allow you to do
they like to have a single protocol
again they make protein fast they die
off fast the cho cells you know once you
have them set up well in your lab
they're much more flexible and the
system actually becomes a bit more of a
a mini stable cell line production
system and so in this case here what we
actually show is that for instances
where you may want to get you know
maximum protein as fast as possible we
do have recommendations that we can
provide for ultra high density
transfection so transfecting the cells
at 10 or even 12 million cells per mil
and what's shown in the blue curve is
that transfecting at 10 million cells
per mil you can see how much faster the
titer comes up compared to transfecting
at the standard 6 million cells per mil
part of the kit protocol so this you
know can be very useful for quick
expression runs where you're looking you
know in four-day window or short window
to come up with some preliminary results
and again you know we can provide
certainly suggestions on how to get the
cells you know in a healthy state to
allow for good transfection we in
general have to in this case increase
the the volume of the DNA xpect amine
complex ation reaction up to 3 mils so
we're needing to add about 1.5 times as
much DNA for the higher cell density and
again you know this is very beneficial
for quick screens and potentially for
toxic or membrane proteins if you're you
know looking to express them very
quickly at small at small scale so this
can increase your your volumetric
productivity of course at the same time
with this many cells you're going to
have more metabolic wastes and at later
times in culture the the 10 million cell
condition will start to taper off the
cells will stop making protein and the
six million cells will eventually catch
up to them so again this is a strategy
for much shorter duration expression
runs
so talk just a little bit about
expression data and I know this table is
probably a bit hard to see but I just
wanted to you know highlight these are
data from external labs in which you
know we we have you know documented fold
increases comparing the XP Cho system to
the current system that they were using
and you can see in many instances you
know these are can be double digits four
or five fold more you know significantly
for example in this case you know
greater than three grams per liter for
this particular antibody on the on the
left hand column but I think importantly
also is the instances where in the
middle column to human antibodies could
not be made in the SP 293 system or
precipitated whereas XP Cho shown in red
was able to give a third to a half a
gram per liter and again on the right
hand column for some by specific
molecules the the Cho settle seemed to
do a very good job of expressing the
sort of a typical type proteins and
again in red you see two by specific
antibodies that could not be made in the
previous Cho system and they were
obtaining again over half a gram so
three-quarters of a gram per liter in
the XP Cho system and and what we've
seen in general XP Cho seems to do an
excellent job for expressing murine
antibodies while antibodies of all
species but murine antibodies in
particular compared to the human 293
cells and then in this slide we show a
direct comparison of the xB Cho system
to xB 293 for a panel of twenty rabbit
monoclonal antibodies and what you see
here in blue is the XP CHEO titers mean
two and a half fold improvement over xB
293 higher for each one of the
antibodies expressed and again for map
nineteen we had a couple hundred mix per
liter of this antibody and xB Cho
nothing detectable and xB 293 and then
one in body that for whatever reason did
not express in either system so again
you know I think at the end of the day
each of these expression systems has its
own benefits pros and cons and working
in concert between xB 293 and xB Cho
largely ensures that you will be
able to make the protein the particular
protein that you're looking to express
in one of those systems some work here
just shown in terms of FA B generation
in XP chill very does a very good job of
generating fabs here we have C and n
terminal hissed at proteins and then we
are currently in a number of
collaborations expressing membrane
proteins in XP show both gpcrs ion
channels etc and to date we've seen very
good expression of membrane proteins and
very good activity of those proteins in
XP Chau compared to either bacteria or
293 based systems so another good
alternative for membrane proteins as
well and again in those instances thus
far we've used lower amounts of DNA
around 0.2 to 0.4 micrograms per mil we
have very good expression of membrane
proteins in about 2 to 4 days here I
just wanted to highlight a publication
recently you that moved from 2 9 3 cells
to XP Cho to make these these very large
HIV nanoparticles for immunization and
in the initial testing of XP Cho they
were able to generate a 20-fold increase
in particle yield from XP Chotu XP to 93
and then we actually met with this lab
and and provided a couple of additional
tips and moved to the temperature
shifted max titer protocol and they were
actually able to increase that to a
sixty fold increase over over 293 cells
and even more importantly than that is
that the XP Cho material derived
material was a very clean single peak by
Sec whereas the 293 was all was always
multiple peaks which required an upfront
additional processing step in the 293
cells whereas XP chello actually allowed
for this very nice single peak of this
very complex nanoparticle to completely
eliminate the upfront purification that
was having to be done with the 293 cells
so a really interesting case study on a
very hard to express protein complex as
a proof of concept we automated XP Cho
on the ampere system and in the interest
of time I won't go into this too much
but suffice it to say is that the only
difference in running XP zero on the
automated system versus the - nine
threes is the transfection complex ation
and so in that case again we simply
doubly dilute the plasmid DNA and then
we allow the robot to add the NEET X
with effect amino reagent to the plasmid
DNA mix twice and then inoculate the
vessel immediately thereafter so just a
slight difference in programming but XP
Cho runs very well on the automated
systems just a note on purification so
all of these expression systems are
different they have different components
in them and they behave somewhat
differently in terms of both
clarification filtration purification
really not surprising we generally
recommend for XP Cho because the the
supernatant can be a bit gooey or if you
will because of a long expression run
and the high cell densities we recommend
you know five to eight thousand times G
spin step to really pellet down a lot of
the components the non protein
components and this allows for much
easier filtration through the point to 2
micron filters also depth filters do a
very good job of handling the
supernatant a one key difference and
this is also in a application note
that's on line is that the XP Cho
supernatant does a better job being
purified with either at risk or have
these buffers using the map select shore
columns protein a columns rather than
the phosphate buffers and we do call
this out in the in the purification
optimization note and then again for xB
Cho you know ion exchange polishing
steps exa eex also will do an excellent
job you know getting to 99% purity of
the antibodies but this one difference
in buffer is quite important as almost
all protein a resins recommend using
phosphate and if phosphate is something
that you you need to use there are other
strategies that we can share with you
four best purification in the phosphate
buffers but in general trade
Happy's have been shown to be very
effective at good recovery and good
clean up above the protein in terms of
characterization I'll just take a minute
to show some some gels here we're not
reduced and reduced gels Forex bicho IgG
in a standard high or max titer protocol
expressing at 0.6 1.1 and 2 grams per
liter versus stable Cho s and versus xB
293 so a very consistent post protein a
purification profiles if we look at SEC
for xB Cho standard titer harvested in
the top panel at day 5 or day 8 in the
middle panel high titer at day 5 day 11
and in the bottom panel day 5 and day 14
for the max titer protocol you can see
that in each case we have a good monomer
peak just past protein a purification
and consistently about 4 to 4 to 5
percent high molecular weight aggregate
regardless of the titer or the
expression protocol used and then once
we have further clean these up with ion
exchange we can easily see 99% plus
purity of the antibodies lastly I just
wanted to note glycans so if we look at
the same molecule expressed in XP Cho a
stable Cho s cell line or XP to 93 we
see the significant differences in the
glycosylation profiles so stable Cho s
and X B Cho in the top and middle
figures show very similar profiles with
primarily g0f glyco forms whereas in the
bottom panel XP to 93 you see much lower
g0f and more g1f glyco forms for X B to
93 so again as I mentioned in the very
first slides you know we see like
oscillation patterns between stable Cho
s or GMP cell line and XP cho that are
that are very similar again however
these may be different than other cho
cell lines maintained in different
media's different feed at different
production conditions which is why the
potential to modulate the glycans is
important going forward as I mentioned
there's some three application notes
online on the left is just the essential
protocol guide with many FAQ s many of
the things that I've talked about today
in the middle is the application note
for scale down of the system 2496 deep
wall plates as well as the 50ml spin
tubes and on the right is the guidance
for a protein a purification in the XP
Cho system and lastly there have been a
number of papers but I call out to in
general one was very early work very
nice work done at Alexi on comparing the
XP Cho system to 293 cells and other
expression systems and on the right is
the paper that I mentioned recently
published about these trimeric HIV
antigens nanoparticles expressed in the
XP Cho system with another publication
on this coming out shortly so I just
wanted to take a moment and thank the
the team that has worked in and
continues to work on XP Cho to support
different needs and applications Chao
and Lou the lead scientist on both the X
b-29 3 and the X B Cho systems GN Lou
who's responsible for the cell line
engineering the scale up and scale down
molecular biology Wendy and Kyle that
have been working diligently on scale-up
as well as the amber bioreactor so what
I did not have time to go into today is
some of the wave scale-up work that has
been completed up to the 10 liter scale
so we hope to have that in an
application note in the in the coming
months as well as Melissa cross who is
our on-site media engineering expert and
Lina and panda who does our protein
purification and characterization and so
with that I will stop I know we're close
on time but if there are any questions
we can answer them now and of course
there are other mechanisms through
expression world to have those questions
addressed as well so thank you very much
for your time thank you dr. zmuda for
that very informative presentation it's
time for Q&A if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button will answer as many
questions as we have time for if we are
unable to get to your question you will
receive a follow-up email after the
presentation let's get started
the first question is what are the most
important considerations as we get ready
to use xkho for the first time so great
great question and the again going back
in our in our slide deck to to matching
so firstly ensuring that your cells are
growing as expected that's the the most
important thing for any of the protocols
that the cells are thawing well growing
as expected and then secondly again it
is matching the conditions from the the
shake flasks with the volumes to be
transfected and understanding your
instrumentation the shaking orbits and
the speeds so I think as you as you
proceed to get the system started in
your lab you know please do read through
the protocol follow those steps in there
they again have been empirically
determined for optimal performance
ensure that the cells are growing well
and within the ranges provided in the
protocol and then ensure that you're
following the recommendations in the
table that we have here and and really
that first step the key of matching
speed and and volume to flask ratios and
orbiting diameter is absolutely critical
for getting the system up and running
correctly great thank you for that
answer and we'll wrap up with one more
question and that question is what are
the most important considerations as we
get ready to use XP ciao for the first
time I think that's a repeat question
I'm sorry what is the best way to verify
that the system is running optimally
once we start using it
and so I'll back up again on my slides
one more time this is a key
you know this slide is very critical and
as I mentioned here the best way to
ensure that you're getting the protein
yields that you should be is is to
utilize our positive control rabbit IgG
antibody and ensure that your viability
profiles are high all the way through
the expression run and to the time of
harvest and that will indicate that all
of the conditions that I just mentioned
in the previous question are are optimal
and that you should be getting optimum
performance of the cells and I do see
there are a lot of questions in the
queue and we will I do promise to get to
all of them
following the expression world but
because we're out of time right now
we will answer those offline I would
like to once again thank dr. zmuda for
his presentation I would also like to
thank lab roots and get Co part of
thermo Fisher Scientific for making
today's educational webcast possible
additional questions will be answered
and published on Thermo Fisher
Scientific sweb site you will receive an
email notification when answers are
available before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through April 2018 you will receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you soon goodbye